so do you play word or at all wordle
yeah watching someone play wordle is
actually really [ __ ]
it's actually really [ __ ]
entertaining to see how their mind works
and just like what guesses they make
like i remember we were in like a like a
long road trip or something and just
like joey was playing word all in like
the front seat and me and connor were
just like silently judging and
commentating in the back fox you would
type in words that weren't real and we
all do it
yeah because everyone does it but it's
funny to be like oh you really think
like flubble is
it gets to the point where you're just
like this has to be a word i don't know
because you just started randomly doing
it and i hate it when people are
watching me because i'm just like don't
judge me i know this is not real no we
all do it but like it's so entertaining
watching someone else do it
it's like you [ __ ] idiot yeah it's
like that's not a real one
what were though i thought the tactic
was like i have like three words i
always use yeah yeah yeah yeah
i've stopped doing that but i realize
it's boring yeah
i just i just i just go with like my
whatever i feel like now but joey's
still on like the [ __ ] crane meta
like yeah i think the crane metal works
i i don't play wordle anymore oh yeah
that was such a big thing everyone on
twitter was posting their little squares
yeah what is that i feel like i missed
the train i was i was very late to it
because i was too scared to ask what the
squares were
i was like you were too scared i was
like is this like some cult or something
that like people are coming in the same
way so i would click on the replies of
the squares because people will ask and
then and then i get the answer right
yeah see i wasn't smart like once i
started playing it you could tell like
there there were some people on your
feet that that are just like you are you
are cheating i know you're [ __ ]
cheating this this word progression
makes zero [ __ ] sense and you'd see
them like they try to like mix it up
sometimes they'd get like threes and
fours but they get too many twos to be
like really to be like universally makes
sense you know
i know you guys are out there i know you
gotta stop doing the world cheetahs yeah
yeah yeah
why why i can tell okay we can all tell
you
social media yeah exactly
wow you're good at wordle that's so
[ __ ] hot
so heading to my dms right now
dude got the two
i'm breaking up oh yeah yeah that's
right come on like get it getting it too
naturally is [ __ ] like oh it's so
sexy it's so [ __ ] satisfying you know
why would you fake that face end it
pretty quickly i don't see this yeah
everything else online yeah yeah
yeah yeah trends online just it moves
too fast now yeah so fast is it is it's
morbid time funny still no no by the
time this is out now yeah no i know it
it's like crazy yeah yeah remember four
guys
oh people still play fall guys though
people do that
was it even a meme before i mean there
were like there was like a period where
there were some memes you know varying
in hilarity it was like nothing compared
to among us no no it came up right
before among us so yeah yeah
yeah among us
oh my gosh i mean those memes still
about my money yes i don't even like
playing the game i just love the memes
yeah yeah
i'm almost everywhere
so you've been on youtube for ten plus
years right do you like a favorite era
of youtube when
when you're like honestly i like my
league parody song days because that was
that [ __ ] was fun i'm like yeah let me
everyone was doing league parody i mean
i used to unironically listen to like
insta lock yeah well i know i mean they
were cute cool i thought i never know
when i go back i'm like why did i what
did i want it was like it was like a
cool era where everyone was trying to
take songs like make parodies out of it
to make it fit like league of legends
because that's fair use parody so i
would like to take like these weep songs
and like yeah um
you know it's really cringe obvious yeah
yeah but it was fun cause i would draw
everything myself and do everything
myself
that was creatively fulfilling yeah for
me and that was super fun for me i like
that that was a period when people still
enjoy league as well yeah and then those
remember oh god do you guys remember the
league ciphers by any chance yeah yeah
they're rapping for me it was really i'm
not surprised
there's still a really big thing for
anime ciphers oh my god someone invite
me to one i want to do one i know a
bunch of people who would yeah i know a
bunch of people who yeah i want to do
more like anime's life is still a thing
yeah yeah please i want to do more like
anime like just like projects if you
need me to found of anything or just
like be in the project
i'm desperate like
are you desperate give me your all
[ __ ] say that pretend like you're
busy yeah
it's funny because we're like
i'm desperate every count every anime
content creator knows trying to get out
of anime now yeah yeah i kind of miss
it's like nostalgic i just wanted to
cute silly things again you know like
whether it's a [ __ ] i would even do a
bridge series you know i don't [ __ ]
care man
i think you said a british series there
a british british
pretty good british accent so if you
need someone to voice a british
character for you let me just drink up
my bottle of water
you sound like a british person with a
concussion really
like you haven't had it had a bit too
much to drink you got a bit too much
gamer stuff trash taste in the
description
just gave up there
like you just went back to america yeah
oh my god accents um so when i audition
for stuff sometimes they want accents
right yeah my biggest like okay
when they asked for an asian accent
what does that even mean though what
does that even mean do you like the pro
cd video where he's like when they asked
me to audition with an asian accent oh i
saw that
and i'm like i feel so racist like what
do you want me to do what accent do you
want me to possibly do yeah it's like an
amalgamation of like chinese creams
so here's it i did they wanted a
japanese accent right yeah and i didn't
know how to do it so i just winged it
for my audition because i need i want
roles man can i can i hear it
but the thing is i got a call back for
that role they're like yeah we really
liked it i'm like what what was i saying
and i had to re-listen to my i'm like
this is not a japanese accent
i mean
yeah
what is the accent really it's just
katakana right it's just it's just
pronouncing things in the category oh my
name is you know it's like this isn't
like that um that's pretty normal though
yeah actually yeah yeah yeah yeah it
just felt weird because it feels like
you're mocking someone who's
what i hear from like media like other
game characters with accents i try to
emulate those yeah it's just when they
ask for like an asian accent it's always
like i'm on like put on the spot i'm
like what do you want me to do that's a
red flag
it's almost like it shouldn't be an
asian accent yeah there's a lot of
countries
right like are you like like what if i
ask you anyone is technically asian yeah
like what if i asked you to do a
european accent like what is what is a
european accent yeah well yeah even when
they say like american or british it's
like well you can there's a lot of yeah
very specific it's just like you just do
what you think is right and then if they
like it they like it if they don't like
it you know
you do a korean accent oh
i just feel so bad doing it like i i i
don't mean to make fun of anything like
yeah it's just me
really trying but i feel like people
will take it the wrong way
i've done i've done some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
yeah
but you never know like someone [ __ ]
clips it twitter like that's true that's
true
you're a veteran
but also aren't you like aren't you
korean as well yeah i am korean yeah
yeah so you're allowed it's fine
surely surely it's your career you're
allowed to attempt the career the
viewers know this but i've done like
i've voiced like an african in the game
and that was not my proudest moment but
that was in a game it's my favorite
moment
everyone loves it because it's literally
like
before the uganda knuckles meme
and it was literally that action yeah
and then like but they they selected me
for some [ __ ] reason sometimes
you never know what they select you for
you know it could be the way that you
say certain things or like but it's it
was weird because when you started voice
acting right like that wasn't like a
thing yet where everyone was like you
can't do this voice if you're not uh
that right kind of yeah
ethnicity these days like they want like
yeah now you have an asian character
they want an asian people yeah yeah it's
like they're very like because you know
like a league changed a lot of the voice
actors like very secretly yeah some of
the characters it wasn't wasn't lucian
voiced patrick yeah yeah yeah uh so
lucian and renekton were the same person
and it's a white guy patrick seitz he's
done like so many patrick really good
he's amazing uh but yeah they very
quietly changed his voice in the game
into uh
because it was weird like i mean like
obviously the when it all started
changing and uh it kind of just changed
overnight like everyone was like that's
not cool
or what yeah well i mean it's just you
know a lot of it now it's like all right
well obviously and it makes sense
obviously a black person should play a
black person right and a white person
should probably play a white person i
[ __ ] you know i don't i don't care
i'll just audition for the thing now
i just love looked forward if you like
it i'm just trying to like avoid the
minefield i'm like am i good i'm good
okay i'm good i'm good yeah
yeah yeah sometimes i'm like what it's
like something i say
online and i wake up and there's 8 000
notifications like billy did you see
that's my nightmare yeah i mean i mean
like that's that's like the ten years
worth of like streaming experience to be
like i need to be careful about
everything i say i probably sound really
like the ptsd
i think if your intent is very clear it
won't
yeah
thank god we cut that stuff she said
earlier
crazy
no because like luckily we're on a
podcast so like even we can like edit it
but like as a twitch streamer being
online so much
like i'm scared you know i'm scared like
i would let something slip or something
would get taken out of context yeah and
it could be totally like unintentional
or like a mistake or whatever but that
moment could like define a lot of things
yeah so you just you know just just
don't do it forehead
just get good you can't get it just be
careful
wow it's that easy yeah wow